roogie who recently split from her
husband Josh Duhamel healthy now joining
me now with more from your interview
with the music star yeah Nance Fergie
clearly an open book while promoting her
brand-new album double duchess we also
had to push back to a flirty classic
when a certain this is AA star was the
object of her music video affections you
Dave Milo Ventimiglia his big break too
and my girls don't cry do you watch this
as a yes I do watch this is us I got
kidding me I do live on this planet
it was super fun shooting that video
because I got to you know have some of
the fun that Josh gets to have on his
movies and but I didn't know how to make
out for camera I just had to tell him
please help me with this he a good
teacher he was so great that was a
decade ago and just look at Fergie now
the 42 year old mama is single and
smoking is this her revenge body now is
there any part of you that is like we
had this breakup I went into the gym I'm
my fiercest I've ever been oh yeah no
she's there all the time on face I it's
not even a big deal yeah we see each
other up and down and all of it it
doesn't matter
Fergie's visual album double duchess is
out today son Axl makes a special cameo
singing the opening lyrics of all short
a lot of these songs are from several
relationships in my life not always
romantic by the way were you inspired by
Beyonce I know you love her she released
a visual album but this is different
it's completely different than Beyonce's
but absolutely she's an inspiration to
me in all areas Fergie and Josh are
making co-parenting their priority but
what's next Kelly Clarkson has signed up
for the voice would you go are you
thinking voice maybe American Idol still
looking for judges is there time in your
schedule I don't have you already signed
up just Fergie yeah
[Music]
you